TALK TO ONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN TOTALLY
SILENT AFTER THE ANARCHISTS AND
OTHER RADICALS HAVE BEEN
ATTACKING OUR HISTORIC
MONUMENTS.
SO WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT THEY
REALLY THINK, WHY ARE THEY
HIDING?
WE REACHED OUT TO ALL 47
DEMOCRATS IN THE SENATE AND TO
GO INDEPENDENCE AS WELL AS
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI.
HERE WAS HER QUESTION.
"DO YOU SUPPORT CHANGING THE
NAMES OF ANY MONUMENTS,
COLLEGES, CITIES OR STATES NAMED
AFTER GEORGE WASHINGTON,
THOMAS JEFFERSON OR
JAMES MADISON?
IF NOT PLEASE EXPLAIN WHY.
GUESS HOW MANY RESPONDED?
ONE.
SENATOR JOE MANCHIN AND HE
DIDN’T EVEN ANSWER THE QUESTION.
THIS ISN’T ABOUT CONFEDERATE
STATUES, AND NEVER WAS.
IT’S ABOUT DESTROYING OUR
CULTURE AND OUR HISTORY AND THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY IS JUST HAPPY TO
LET IT ALL HAPPENED IF IT
DEFEATING DONALD TRUMP.
HE RESPONDS TO THE SILENCE OF
HIS COLLEAGUES, MISSOURI
SENATOR JOSH ALI.
IT SHOULDN’T BE A HARD QUESTION
TO ANSWER.
IT’S KIND OF A "YES" OR "NO"
DEAL WITH THE SHORTEST NATION.
BUT THEY ALL COWED AND DECIDED
TO HIDE.
REACTION?
>> I CAN’T SAY I’M AT ALL
SURPRISED BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THE
UNITED STATES SENATE, SENATE
DEMOCRATS WATCHING THE STATUES
OF WASHINGTON AND
ULYSSES S. GRANT, NOW LINK AND
COME DOWN AND AT THE SAME TIME
THEY’RE TRYING TO FORCE RENAMING
OF ALL OF OUR MILITARY BASES AND
WAR MEMORIALS.
TAKING THOSE DOWN BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS WITHOUT ANY PUBLIC
DISCUSSION, THIS IS THEIR AGENDA
AND IT DOESN’T HAVE ANYTHING TO
DO WITH PURSUING JUSTICE OR
UNIFYING THE COUNTRY, THIS IS
ALL ABOUT POLITICAL CALCULATION
AND TRYING TO SATISFY THE CANCEL
CULTURE THAT THEY ARE PUSHING
FORWARD AND IT’S A MISTAKE, IT’S
DIVIDING THE COUNTRY, IT’S THE
WRONG THING TO DO.
>> Laura: MY ANKLE LEGISLATE
OUT, HOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE USING
THESE EXTREMISTS AS A PROXY
CAMPAIGN FOR BIDEN AND THAT’S
WHY THEY ARE ALLOWING THEM TO DO
WHAT THEY’RE DOING AND NOT
COMMENTING ON IT BECAUSE THEY
THINK FOR NOW AT LEAST IT’S
HELPING THEM.
DO YOU SEE THAT IN THE FUTURE
CHANGING IT ALL?
>> I THINK AMERICANS ARE NOT
GOING TO WANT TO SEE OUR HISTORY
ERASED FULL SALE.
PROTESTERS IN DAYS D.C. SAY THEY
ARE GOING TO PULL DOWN STATUES
OF ABRAHAM LINCOLN, I DON’T
THINK THIS IS WHERE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE.
WE CAN HAVE A CONVERSATION AS A
COUNTRY ABOUT FOR INSTANCE
MILITARY BASES, WE OUGHT TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION IN PUBLIC
TOGETHER.
LIKE WE WOULD AS A FAMILY, WE
OUGHT TO DO IT OUT IN THE OPEN
WHICH IS WHAT I PROPOSED, I’VE
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD STOP THE DEMOCRATS
MANDATORY BACK DOOR, BACK ROOM
RENAMING OF ALL OF THESE BASES
AND TAKING DOWN THESE MEMORIALS
TO FALLEN SOLDIERS AND SAY,
LET’S HAVE A CONVERSATION OUT IN
THE OPEN AND INVOLVE EVERYBODY,
LET’S BE REASONABLE ABOUT THIS
BUT THAT’S NOT WHAT THEY WANT
AND I THINK THEY’RE GOING TO
FIND THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE TIRED OF THE CANCEL CULTURE,
TIRED OF THE WOKE MOB AND THEY
WANT TO MOVE HOLD ONTO WHO WE
ARE TOGETHER AND FIND COMMON
GROUND.
>> Laura: I THINK THEY WANT AN
END TO THIS MADNESS AND SO FAR A
LOT OF YOUR COLLEAGUES SEEM TO
BE HIDING AS WELL, THEY WILL
ISSUE A TWITTER STATEMENT EVERY
NOW AND THEN BUT I’M NOT SEEING
A LOT OF LEADERSHIP FOR MANY
REPUBLICANS ON THE HILL OTHER
THAN YOU ON THIS AND I KNOW YOUR
OFFERING YOUR LEGISLATION TO TRY
TO COMBAT WHAT SENATOR WARREN IS
DOING TO RUSH THE RENAMING OF
ALL THESE BIG PIECES BUT
SENATOR, NANCY PELOSI, I’VE GOT
TO GET TO THIS BECAUSE SHE
ACCUSED REPUBLICANS OF TRYING TO
"GET AWAY WITH MURDER" WITH OUR
POLICING REFORM BILL AND TODAY
NANCY DOUBLED DOWN ON THAT, I
JUST PLAY THE SOUND BITE
CHUCK SCHUMER HAS BACKED HER,
WATCH.
>> DO YOU THINK IT WAS
APPROPRIATE FOR SPEAKER PELOSI
TO SAY THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
"GETTING AWAY WITH MURDER?"
>> SHE’S ANSWER THAT QUESTION
HERSELF AND WHAT SHE SAID WAS
FINE WITH ME.
>> Laura: WHAT SHE SAID IS
"I’M NOT APOLOGIZING AND THAT’S
WHAT I BELIEVE" DESPITE THE FACT
THAT THE LEGISLATION WAS OFFERED
BY SENATOR TIM SCOTT,
AFRICAN-AMERICAN SENATOR, THEY
DON’T WANT TO EVEN DEBATE ON
THIS.
>> YOU KNOW, WHEN SENATOR SCOTT
PUT FORWARD HIS PROPOSAL THE
DEMOCRATS TOOK TO THE SENATE
FLOOR AND CALLED IT HER TOKEN
WHICH SENATOR SCOTT POINTED OUT
IS A WORD THAT IS SOMETIMES USED
NOT IN A VERY NICE WAY, THEY
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY’RE DOING,
THEY ARE FINE PLAYING THE RACE
BAITING GAME WHEN IT’S AGAINST
REPUBLICANS, FIND USING THAT
KIND OF LANGUAGE AS IT RELATES
TO SENATOR SCOTT WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY ABHORRENT AND
RIDICULOUS.
THIS IS AGAIN ALL ABOUT
POLITICS, THEY WANT WHAT THEY
THINK IS AN ISSUE THAT THEY CAN
TAKE TO I GUESS THE PEOPLE THEY
THINK ARE A KEY PART OF THEIR
VOTING COALITION WHICH IS THIS
WOKE MOB AND THE CANCEL CULTURE
WHICH THESE DEMOCRATS ARE
PUSHING FORWARD AND EMBRACING
AND I’D SAY AGAIN, LAURA, I
THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
TIRED OF THIS, I THINK THEY WANT
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION TOGETHER
LIKE ADULTS AND WANT TO FIND
COMMON GROUND AND THAT’S WHAT WE
SHOULD BE TRYING TO DO.
>> Laura: THIS FINALLY, VERY
QUICKLY, YOUR REACTION TO THE
APPEALS COURT IN D.C. REVERSING
THAT LOWER COURT DECISION TO PUT
OFF DISMISSING THE FLYNN CASE,
BIG VICTORY FOR GENERAL FLYNN
TODAY.
IS SOMEONE GOING TO FINALLY PAY
FOR WHAT HAPPENED TO
GENERAL FLYNN?
>> WILL TELL YOU WHAT, LAURA,
CONGRESS, THE UNITED STATES
SENATE HAS A JOB TO DO HERE IN
FIGURING OUT HOW IN THE WORLD
THIS CASE WHERE YOU HAVE THE
FBI, THE CAREER FBI FOLKS SAY
THERE’S NOTHING HERE, WE SHOULD
MOVE ON AND THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE GETS INVOLVED IN
INVOLVED AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
THEY’RE GOING GANGBUSTERS AFTER
FLYNN, SAME THING WITH THE FISA
COURT, THE FBI LYING TO GET A
WARRANT TO TAP THE DONALD TRUMP
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN IN THE
MIDDLE OF AN ELECTION, WHAT IS
GOING ON HERE?
WHAT IS GOING ON AT THE FBI,
WHAT WAS THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE’S
INVOLVEMENT, THESE ARE THINGS WE
NEED TO FIND OUT AND PEOPLE DO